so you're obviously not a new artist  this is you've been how long have you  been active doing the rap [ __ ] i've been  really rapping since the 90s literally  since the 90s i had my first deal when i  was 11. but i passed up on  wow i'm 31.  so it's 20 years right there's just  instead of working that's crazy so  you've seen a lot man yeah i've been on  the road i mean i'd have been on the  road with booster like  years ago did you ever did you ever  think about signing with him because you  know  nah like  as my boy was you know you know i'm  saying like  i can't see me signing you know we we we  we move like from here appear here's a  piece yeah like we feel like we two  bosses yeah i'm saying two  we two bosses so i just i just soaked up  a lot of games from like i i learned  from his hustle like watching him do  three four shows a night that was crazy  on the road when he got out of jail i  never seen like uh  man the bags he was grabbing i watched  them